[Music]
[Applause]
i've also spent a lot of time this week
on name image and likeness
i'm fascinated of what it is and where
it's going and i liken this to a tax
loophole that everybody's trying to take
advantage of now because they're going
to close this up at some point heather
denich knows a whole lot more about this
than i do she's a senior writer for
espn.com
and well let me start
with the beginning of this week heather
how would you recap what happened this
week in college football with name image
and likeness
well i would recap it by saying it
became the perfect storm really with
um
i mean throw it into a blender with a
transfer portal and
that's where you have what happened
at pitt and you've got their star wide
receiver putting his name in the
transfer portal i mean i spoke to their
quarterback now keaton slovis who up and
moved his collegiate life across the
country to go to pitt to play there in
large part because of that receiver and
now he might not be there and and that's
just kind of shows where we are um but
this has been happening for a long time
i think the issue of the transfer portal
has exacerbated what you're seeing with
name image and likeness
yeah and i wondered you have the pac-12
and sec commissioners going to
washington dc
what are they lobbying for
well they're lobbying for legislative
help meaning somebody tell us what the
rules are and then it's fascinating to
me that those are the two people who are
going not ncaa president mark emmert
who's on his way out and you know to
have these two commissioners who are
literally two of the most powerful
people in college athletics right now
one from the state of california which
is a very blue state one from the sec
which represents a lot of red states
united as they walk into the united
states senate to meet with these
senators i think sends a very powerful
message about not only how serious they
are about asking for help but to be
quite blunt how desperate college
athletics is for some guidance because
clearly they have not gotten it from
indianapolis and i feel like they're
almost circumventing the ncaa they're
just saying you know you guys just stay
there in your little bubble in
indianapolis we're going to take care of
this we're going to be on the initiative
there and you know greg sankey is as
power he's more powerful than mark
emirate is uh how is name image and
likeness bad for college football
well i think time will tell just how bad
it is because again you've got you can't
talk about that without talking about
the transfer portal how many kids are
going to be in the portal with nowhere
to go right i mean it's bad right this
skinny minute because
coaches have no idea who's on their
roster right everything ties into
something else which is why they're
trying to get these transfer windows one
in the last november uh excuse me the
last sunday of november that leads up to
early signing day and another window
kind of around now mid april to may 1st
which is currently the only deadline to
put your name in the portal right now is
may 1st and so they're hoping well if at
least we narrow these windows it'll help
coaches tell who on their roster like
but to the example of slovis at pit guys
have to know who they're playing with
too they have to know what they're
signing up for when they move i mean i
spoke with one athletic director when i
was in scottsdale last week who told
this anecdote of we had this great
linebacker who wanted a car and so he
goes to the local car dealership and
says hey you know on the up and up what
can we do to help this kid out the car
dealers like wow i'm not really
comfortable with that so the kid leaves
goes and gets his car somewhere else
and tweets a picture of it by the way so
that's kind of where it is and so to be
able to have some legislation and look
there's no
nobody is kind of blind to the reality
of everyone knows how slow things work
in congress they're not gonna because
they had this meeting changed things
today and bob bolesby the outgoing big
12 commissioner was very clear about
that saying you know it's not like
anything is going to change before the
midterm elections anyway but to start
those conversations and ask for help i
think is
an important step be it symbolic or not
in where college athletics is
why don't we just pull back the curtain
on this heather and just say let's have
a super conference let's have 40 of the
top football programs and you could
almost structure it like the nfl and and
just say look
this is big business you're getting paid
come on in
uh get out of the habs and the have-nots
then you have everybody going to one a
or whatever it's going to be but
that just feels like that's where we're
headed
it does but everybody has to pump the
brakes on that like we look at it
through tunnel vision like everyone is
the sec which it's not college football
and college athletics as a whole is far
broader than the ohio states and
alabama's of the world right so there
has to be some recognition of the
olympics force of title ix how that
impacts the softball players the
baseball players i mean you name it
right
and so
there is an aspect to that now when i
was in scottsdale ohio state athletic
director gene smith he's one of the
veteran people in college athletics when
he talks people listen he said why
don't we put the 10 fbs conferences
under the college football playoff
umbrella let's rethink this whole thing
as we think playoff expansion and his
idea is the ncaa can continue to host
championships for those olympic sports
and men's and women's hoops and we'll
deal with this here with football and
some people say that's not a bad idea
but we need a sort of vp of operations
for college football like a dan gavitt
who does the same thing for college
basketball um so you know people are at
least starting to think out of the box
but you can't
not
remember these other college athletic
athletes i mean you know i met the
michigan state athletic director for the
first time who's almost in tears he was
so emotional about his gymnastics team
and what they accomplished four years
after um the larry nasser scandal and so
just
people care there are people who care
about those other athletes
thank you heather and uh we'll be
watching thanks for joining us
thanks dan that's heather dennis she
covers college football espn insider
national college football writer
espn.com